bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 épisode 237 nous
sommes au salon de l'agriculture et mon
invité ce soir et la vice-présidente de
la Région Île-de-France en charge de
l'agriculture Valérie Lacroute
[Musique]
la croûte bonsoir bonsoir merci de votre
invitation merci d'être avec nous alors
vous êtes ancienne député de
Seine-et-Marne et maire de Nemours vous
êtes depuis 2021 vice-présidente de la
Région Île-de-France chargée de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation vous
faites partie donc de la majorité de
Valérie Pécresse au conseil régional
l'Île-de-France une région agricole ça
peut paraître pour certains un peu
paradoxal mais pourtant c'est bien le
cas tout à fait effectivement et vous
avez raison de le rappeler on a toujours
tendance vu de l'extérieur de se dire
que la région Île-de-France est une
région très urbaine et bien non puisque
pratiquement la moitié des terres sont
des terres destinées à l'agriculture des
terres agricoles ce qui fait notre
richesse et notre fierté et bien
évidemment l'objectif c'est de pouvoir
préserver ces terres foncières même si
il faut en même temps pouvoir développer
cette région Île-de-France donc voilà
des enjeux énormes et ce salon de
l'agriculture et là pour en parler le
chiffre exact 49% du territoire franc
bien est composé de surface agricoles la
région Île-de-France c'est environ 12
millions d'habitants et c'est autant de
bouche à nourrir même si on habite en
ville l'agriculture c'est ça concerne
vraiment tout le monde oui oui ça
concerne tout le monde et c'est vrai que
la crise en Ukraine ou même le covid a
rappelé à tous les Français et les
Franciliens l'importance de
l'alimentation l'importance de se
nourrir et l'importance de manger des
produits du territoire des produits ce
qu'on appelle en circuit court et c'est
vrai que c'est un enjeu pour notre
région
Île-de-France d'avoir des produits de
qualité alors le salon de l'agriculture
depuis 1964 c'est un événement important
pour le monde agricole c'est aussi
l'occasion pour les urbains pour les
parisiens et pour la la petite couronne
de redécouvrir le champ de redécouvrir
la nature de voir d'échanger avec les
agriculteurs ce qui nous nourrissent
c'est un moment particulier aussi pour
vous en termes politiques j'imagine bien
sûr c'est un moment particulier parce
que c'est vrai que ce salon une fois par
an Salon International de l'Agriculture
donc voilà il y a déjà toutes les
régions de France qui sont représentées
et c'est vrai que pour la région
Île-de-France c'est un moment
exceptionnel c'est l'occasion pour nous
de montrer à nos franciliens qui sont
pour beaucoup qui habitent à Paris ou en
petite couronne ici oui oui c'est la
majorité et puis en plus c'est la
semaine des vacances donc c'est
l'occasion c'est vraiment de montrer ce
que ce qu'est la région Île-de-France ce
que nous avons comme richesse sur ce
territoire et c'est l'occasion pour nous
élu effectivement de la majorité avec
Valérie Pécresse de démontrer que la
région Île-de-France est aux côtés de
ces agriculteurs de ces producteurs et
qu'elle est là pour accompagner au
développement de cette région à la
production agricole alimentaire du
territoire à destination de nos
franciliens donc c'est effectivement un
moment incontournable et puis un moment
très sympathique en même temps alors
l'année dernière le thème c'était les
retrouvailles après une année marquée
par la crise sanitaire et l'annulation
de l'édition 2021 à cause de la pandémie
cette année le thème c'est l'agriculture
le vivant au quotidien alors qu'est-ce
que ces mots vous vous inspire vous
alors le vivant c'est surtout le vivant
et le quotidien Le le mot quotidien qui
est important et je pense que le thème
est bien choisi après ces deux années
difficiles alors même s'il a une
dernière effectivement le thème des
retrouvailles était important c'est
l'occasion de montrer au travers des
événements internationaux que nous avons
vécu au cours de ces deux années
l'importance du vivant de la matière
vivante de l'alimentation du produit qui
est fabriqué et produit par nos
agriculteurs qui doit au quotidien
permettre à tous nos franciliens d'être
de se nourrir et j'ai effectivement je
pense que la thématique elle est elle
est parfaitement adaptée à tout ce que
nous avons vécu ces deux dernières
années et de montrer à nos franciliens
qu'il est important de bien rien alors
on l'a dit l'Île-de-France est une
région agricole malgré les apparences on
y recense 5000 exploitations alors
qu'est-ce qu'on produit en Île-de-France
quels sont les produits locaux alors on
produit beaucoup de choses c'est un peu
le alors entre guillemets pas le
paradoxe mais le le la richesse de cette
de cette terre francilienne c'est qu'on
y produit alors on a je dirais en
Seine-et-Marne des grandes cultures le
premier département agricole
d'Île-de-France donc beaucoup de grandes
cultures ce qui permet de de produire du
blé du colza de l'orge des betteraves
donc ce qui permet aussi d'avoir une
partie d'exportation parce que c'est
aussi ce qui est important c'est de
nourrir au quotidien mais aussi de
pouvoir exporter donc on est plutôt sur
ce cet espace de la Seine-et-Marne
plutôt effectivement sur de la grande
culture nous avons un peu d'élevage donc
c'est là aussi un des enjeux de pouvoir
développer l'élevage et puis la
production maraîchère voilà qui se
développe et qui se développe de plus en
plus sur les zones urbaines parce que
c'est important aussi de pouvoir
produire sur des surfaces qui sont moins
grandes donc c'est là aussi le
l'objectif de pouvoir accompagner la
production de maraîchage de fruits de
légumes on a vu ces dernières années on
a perdu énormément on importe
malheureusement plus de la moitié de nos
fruits et légumes ce qui est dramatique
pour une un territoire comme la France
qui était un territoire très agricole et
puis on est aussi en accompagnement la
région
Île-de-France vers des pratiques plus
vertueuses puisqu'on a aussi accompagné
le bio depuis de nombreuses années au
travers de la production par message
ces dernières années ce qui était aussi
important donc voilà on est assez
diversifié
bien évidemment on est on n'est pas
l'équivalent de de région très agricoles
mais je dirais qu'on n'a pas rougir de
tout ce qu'on fait et la région est
vraiment là pour accompagner ces
producteurs rentrons au niveau politique
à présent après cette présentation
rapide de la région Île-de-France et de
son agriculture pour que nos auditeurs
comprennent bien quels sont les
compétences des régions en matière
d'agriculture parce qu'on sait qu'il y a
l'Union européenne il y a l'état que
font les régions alors c'est une très
bonne question surtout que c'est c'est
une question d'actualité puisque depuis
le 1er janvier 2023 donc il y a quelques
semaines
toutes les régions de France ont
récupéré dans la nouvelle politique
agricole commune le deuxième pilier de
la PAC donc ça parle pas forcément à
tous nos Français mais c'est une
révolution je dirais importante puisque
du coup les régions ont maintenant une
vraie compétence en matière
d'agriculture et donc on est là vraiment
pour accompagner nos agriculteurs l'État
a gardé tout ce qu'on appelle les aides
classique c'est à dire les aides à
l'hectare en fonction du nombre
d'hectares des agriculteurs à repris le
sujet du bio donc on y reviendra
peut-être tout à l'heure parce que c'est
une inquiétude pour pour les
agriculteurs qui se sont convertis en
bio avec le l'inquiétude que l'État
n'accompagne pas autant qu'on peut le
faire les régions ces dernières années
ça avait été un choix de Valérie
Pécresse et donc nous on vient aider les
agriculteurs sur l'installation des
jeunes agriculteurs on y reviendra
peut-être tout à l'heure qui est un
enjeu important sur la transmission des
exploitations là aussi c'est un élément
important et puis après tout ce qui est
investissement tout ce qui est
accompagnement de nos agriculteurs dans
leurs outils de production donc par
exemple la construction de de bâtiments
l'ouverture de boutiques à la ferme tout
ce qui peut permettre aux agriculteurs
de faire face aux changements climatique
aux aléas climatiques donc c'est
vraiment un choix de la région de
pouvoir les accompagner au travers de
cette politique européenne et puis
d'aider aux filières au développement
des filières donc on a aidé la filière
champignon
on a on a élaboré un plan de l'élevage
que nous allons mettre en œuvre mais en
attendant on a aidé on a l'agneau
d'Île-de-France on est en train de
travailler sur les jeunes bovins voilà
donc vraiment l'objectif de la région
c'est de pouvoir accompagner nos
producteurs pour produire sur place et
permettre à nos franciliens de manger
local alors en 2018 la région a adopté
un pacte agricole régional allant donc
de 2018 à 2030 une période de 12 ans un
pacte marqué par 5 axes majeurs alors on
va les détailler d'abord la préservation
des terres et la lutte contre le mitage
alors l'Île-de-France c'est donc 49% de
terre agricoles on l'a dit dans une
région où les projets industriels sont
parfois nombreux avec le notamment
marqué par un développement économique
important dans les années 2000 1800
hectares étaient consommés chaque année
contre hectares en 2019 donc il y a eu
des efforts c'est une préoccupation on
je dirais ancienne cette de cette lutte
contre le mitage en Île-de-France oui
bien sûr c'est une préoccupation déjà
ancienne qui va être encore renforcée là
encore plus puisque on est en train de
d'élaborer le nouveau schéma directeur
de la région Île-de-France le drift eux
alors on a mis le volet environnemental
et en plus avec un objectif national qui
est de limiter l'artificialisation des
sols donc on avait déjà Valérie Pécresse
était déjà engagé dans cette politique
de préservation des terres agricoles qui
va se renforcer là avec ce ce qu'on
appelle le zan la zéro artificialisation
nette et donc c'est c'est vraiment un
enjeu compliqué en même temps puisque
vous l'avez dit on est une région qui se
développe beaucoup on a des villes
nouvelles où il y a un programme
national sur une nouvelle qui est de les
développer d'accueillir des habitants
donc de construire des logements de
mettre de l'activité économique et donc
du coup il y a cette vraiment cet enjeu
de pouvoir trouver le bon équilibre
entre développement économique
préservation du foncier production
alimentaire qui veut dire derrière
souveraineté alimentaire on l'a un petit
peu évoqué tout à l'heure mais c'est
vrai que cette souveraineté alimentaire
elle est essentielle dans les années à
venir il y a eu le plan friche lancé en
2019 sur cette question par la région
pour aider donc les collectivités à
valoriser des zones qui sont à l'abandon
sur leur territoire à travers donc des
appels à manifestation est-ce que les
collectivités ont joué le jeu de ce
plancher les collectivités ont joué le
jeu puisque c'est effectivement le et
c'est une très bonne politique parce que
ça permet d'accompagner les territoires
les communautés de communes ou les
communes qui ont des friches sur leur
territoire et on le sait pourquoi c'est
des friches c'est parce que c'est
compliqué de reconvertir et ça coûte
énormément d'argent alors souvent les
élus locaux et moi je suis maire donc
j'ai eu le cas sur ma commune on a
toujours de bonnes idées pour
reconvertir ces friches sauf que c'est
des budgets très importants et sans
accompagnement en l'occurrence de la
région Île-de-France m'a malheureusement
souvent on ne peut rien faire donc c'est
vraiment une incitation à dire on va pas
consommer de la terre agricole mais on
va reconvertir ces friches industrielles
avec parfois des vieux bâtiments parfois
de la dépollution à faire et ça coûte
cher et donc c'est vraiment de pouvoir
accompagner ces collectivités en se
disant bah il y avait de l'économie il y
avait de la vie sur ces friches il y a
pas de raison qu'on puisse pas les
remettre en activité plutôt que d'aller
grignoter le la terre agricole à côté ou
d'aller grignoter sur les forêts parce
que c'est parfois aussi le cas ou
d'aller tendre un petit village parce
que il y a des terres à côté qui sont
pas forcément cultivées puis c'est plus
facile
quand vous avez un terrain nu devenir et
construire quelque chose qu'un terrain
déjà occupé par un vieux bâtiment pollué
et non utilisé depuis 10 ans bah souvent
on cherche un peu la facilité donc c'est
vraiment c'est une politique de petits
points de dentelle mais qui porte petit
à petit ces fruits et toujours sur cette
question de préservation donc des terres
agricoles il y a aussi ce dossier plus
complexe de Paris Saclay menacé par la
ligne 18 du métro du Grand Paris Express
le 10 février dernier plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de temps écologistes se sont
rassemblés pour dénoncer l'absence de
limite précise de la zone protégée c'est
parfois difficile un peu de trouver
l'équilibre justement vous en parler
entre le les enjeux économiques et les
enjeux agricoles oui tout à fait
effectivement ce dossier il y en a eu il
y en a eu d'autres
et puis sur d'autres territoires de
France où effectivement il y a l'enjeu
de développer le territoire de mailler
le territoire de mieux le desservir pour
permettre à des habitants de se s'est
passé sans grignoter sur sur les terres
fonciers sans déloger un agriculteur et
c'est toute la complexité du
développement effectivement ce sujet
voilà il cristallise un peu donc il faut
qu'il y ait de la concertation il faut
qu'il y ait de l'échange et parfois ça
nécessite de revoir le tracé de
certaines lignes ou de faire des
aménagements à la marge qui vont
permettre de satisfaire tout le monde et
de répondre aux inquiétudes et aux
attentes de chacun de nos concitoyens
deuxième axe du pacte agricole le
renouvellement de la génération
d'agriculteurs alors pourquoi les jeunes
se lancent moins ces dernières années
dans l'agriculture il y a beaucoup de
facteurs je souvent on fait un petit peu
le parallèle avec le désertification
médicale et le départ à la retraite de
médecins ou l'absence de vocation c'est
vrai que pour les agriculteurs c'est
c'est ça aussi on a la moitié de nos
agriculteurs qui ont plus de 60 ans et
qui vont partir à la retraite dans les
dans les 10 années qui viennent donc
effectivement cette vieillissement de la
population cette perte de vocation parce
que c'est un métier difficile surtout
quand on a de l'élevage il faut être là
le weekend il faut être là toute l'année
donc compliqué pour nos jeunes qui ont
pas forcément envie de vivre comme leurs
parents ou leurs grands-parents et qui
ont envie d'avoir une vie personnelle
plus importante et puis des conditions
de travail qui sont pas forcément
faciles et puis la pression de certains
groupuscules certains minorités
écologistes ou même de d'Urbain qui sont
venus s'installer à la campagne et qui
ne veulent pas voir à côté de chez eux
ben une production animale des champs
cultivés des chants traités et donc tous
ces événements ont fait que petit à
petit mais on a eu une perte de vocation
l'objectif
et j'ai envie de dire parfois c'est un
mal pour un bien c'est que la crise en
Ukraine la guerre en Ukraine ou la crise
du covid ont remis en avant
l'importance de l'agriculture et de
produire français on souhaite augmenter
ce nombre de recruteurs alors justement
comment la région peut peut se aider
peut soutenir donc ces jeunes
agriculteurs qui souhaitent et autres
pour augmenter ce nombre dans les années
à venir c'est la chance qu'on a c'est
qu'avec cette nouvelle politique
agricole commune dans le cadre de ce
deuxième pilier la région a pour
compétence d'aider à l'installation des
jeunes agriculteurs de la fameuse dja
dotation pour ces jeunes agricultures et
la région Île-de-France nous avons fait
le choix de mettre le paquet sur cette
Dja et donc nous allons être la région
de France la plus généreuse pour
l'accompagnement financier de de nos
jeunes agriculteurs à leur installation
voilà donc le montant nous allons passer
du net de 12000 euros à 22000 euros plus
les modulations qui qui existent
derrière qui vont permettre à nos
agriculteurs d'avoir un soutien
financier pour leur installation parce
que c'est effectivement une de nos
priorités on est voyez à peu près 120
installations par an pour être bien et
serein il en faudrait 200 par an donc
l'objectif c'est vraiment de pouvoir
inciter des jeunes agriculteurs alors
dans le cas de familial ou hors cadre
familial de s'installer sur la région
Île-de-France pour aider à la production
donc céréalières fruits et légumes
élevage voilà on est on accompagnera
tout jeune agriculteur qui veut
s'installer
[Musique]
toujours avec Valérie lakrouth
vice-présidente de la Région
Île-de-France en charge de l'agriculture
et de l'alimentation troisième axe du
pacte agricole maintenant la
diversification alors pourquoi c'est
important pour une région d'avoir
plusieurs types d'agriculture alors j'ai
envie de dire c'est
pas seulement pour la région c'est aussi
pour nos agriculteurs parce qu'on le
sait on le voit et même le dise
il faut qu'il se diversifie pour
augmenter leurs revenus au quotidien
c'est comme une entreprise il vaut mieux
avoir plusieurs clients qu'un seul parce
que quand vous avez qu'un seul client et
que ce client disparaît et ben c'est
votre activité que vous mettez en péril
et là c'est un peu le même principe
l'idée c'est dire que l'agriculteur plus
il va diversifier son activité et plus
il pourra effectivement
espérer obtenir un revenu supplémentaire
de ces nouvelles activités alors la
région Île-de-France justement c'est
principalement la des cultures
céréalières sur quelles autres filières
les agriculteurs de la région
peuvent-ils se diversifier alors souvent
alors on a un petit peu tous les cas de
figure donc c'est un peu compliqué de
faire une généralité mais on a quand
même beaucoup de d'agriculteurs qui
produisent transforment et donc ouvre ce
qu'on appelle des boutiques à la ferme
ce qui leur permet de vendre vraiment
circuit court toute la production qu'ils
ont pu transformer sur place donc voyez
par exemple je parlais tout à l'heure
d'élevage agneau d'Île-de-France et bien
c'est l'occasion pour ses éleveurs de
vendre leur agneau dans les boucheries
du coin de d'alimenter les cuisines
centrales la restauration collective et
puis devant chez eux dans leur boutique
aux particuliers aux habitants du
territoire voilà un carré d'agneau voilà
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail mais
voilà sur les les fruits les légumes
c'est pareil et puis on a aussi des
agriculteurs ou des industries dans
l'agroalimentaire qui récupèrent tous
les fruits ou les légumes moches entre
guillemets ou qui sont pas calibrés et
qui du coup transforment ces produits et
peuvent vendre en direct une soupe de
potimarron
un coulis de tomates du cresson on a
voilà on a des cultures un peu
emblématiques sur sur la région
Île-de-France et ses activités m'in
génèrent du revenu supplémentaire pour
ces agriculteurs et donc la région
Île-de-France on va aider à l'ouverture
d'une boutique en matière
d'investissement où on va accompagner
l'agriculteur pour faire les travaux
et pour ouvrir sa boutique on va aider
l'agriculteur à construire voilà en gare
pour mettre de l'élevage on va
accompagner un agriculteur pour
développer l'élevage de poules bio vous
voyez et donc c'est vraiment l'objectif
de la région Île-de-France de pouvoir
accompagner ces agriculteurs à se
diversifier et toutes ces nouvelles
filières du coup on va les regrouper sur
des marques créer des marques tout à
fait alors francilienne c'est vraiment
notre notre objectif et on a notre
marque produit en
Île-de-France qui est une marque que
nous avons créée il y a maintenant
quelques années et l'objectif c'est
vraiment qu'on puisse monter en
puissance sur cette marque parce que on
a bien vu on a bien senti que les
Franciliens avaient envie d'acheter du
local et donc il faut qu'ils puissent
identifier rapidement ce qui est en
produit local et pour pouvoir même dans
les grandes surfaces parce que c'est ça
aussi l'objectif
dans les grandes surfaces de pouvoir
quand ils rentrent dans le magasin bah
trouver les produits d'Île-de-France
donc c'est là aussi une des missions qui
est confiée à un de un de mes collègues
conseiller régional Sébastien dromini de
pouvoir faire monter en puissance cette
marque produit en Île-de-France alors
quatrième axe maintenant du pacte
agricole la transition énergétique et
écologique l'agriculture émet en France
19% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre le secteur devra faire des efforts
pour atteindre donc les objectifs du
pacte vert européen alors quels sont les
principaux efforts à faire notamment via
cette nouvelle pacte qui se veut plus
verte alors le le premier objectif pour
nous toujours au travers de ces
investissements c'est de pouvoir
accompagner aussi
financièrement nos agriculteurs dans
cette transition
énergétique écologique et également de
s'adapter aux
aléas climatiques donc aussi bien vous
voyez de d'avoir des des outils qui leur
permettent de faire de l'irrigation
goutte-à-goutte de pouvoir consommer
l'eau parce que c'est un sujet important
le moins possible mais le plus
efficacement possible c'est aussi de les
accompagner dans la construction de de
hangar et de panneaux photovoltaïques
sur les hangars pour pouvoir consommer
moins d'énergie c'est de les aider dans
l'innovation dans l'achat de machines
qui peuvent permettre de de consommer le
moins d'engrais possible puisque on a
voilà des machines qui ont au centimètre
près sont en capacité de de mettre de
l'engrais ou des pesticides mais juste
là où il faut et beaucoup moins qu'avant
puisque c'est ça aussi l'objectif et
donc on a une vraie politique dans ce
domaine là pour qu'il fasse face qu'il
fasse face au changement climatique et
qu'il puisse aussi se préserver contre
ces aléas climatiques
de l'agriculture il y a aussi les
méthaniseurs cette question qui permet
de recycler les déchets agricoles pour
fournir donc de l'énergie renouvelable
du gaz de l'électricité pourtant la
technique ne fait pas l'unanimité
certains dénoncent des effets
secondaires ça se développe en tout cas
en Île-de-France les méthaniseurs est-ce
que c'est l'avenir la méthanisation
alors
est-ce que c'est l'avenir non parce que
enfin oui et non c'est à dire que l'idée
c'est vraiment de dire que il faut qu'on
ait ce qu'on appelle ce mix énergétique
c'est-à-dire ne pas se focaliser sur une
seule énergie dans le même panier
la filière nucléaire et puis de
s'apercevoir maintenant que finalement
si on avait poursuivi le le
l'installation de de de
PR on serait peut-être pas dans cette
situation de crise énergétique mais la
région Île-de-France fait le choix
effectivement de développer toutes ces
énergies vertes et donc on est on a
depuis 2016 mis en place des appels à
projets pour l'installation de
méthaniseur sur la région Île-de-France
donc on accompagne alors on a beaucoup
accompagné les méthaniseurs agricoles
avec quand même pour soucis mais la
réglementation est là pour s'assurer que
les agriculteurs ne font pas n'importe
quoi pour soucis bien évidemment que
l'agriculteur ne produise pas uniquement
pour mettre son méthaniseur ça a été la
polémique qu'on a pu voir en Allemagne
il y a 10-15 ans la France c'était
justement à ce moment là il y a une
petite dizaine d'années fait une petite
pause pour regarder ce que faisait les
Allemands et éviter de faire la même
chose et là on a depuis 2016 une
politique assez incitative
financièrement pour aider les
agriculteurs à effectivement quand ça se
justifie quand c'est possible en termes
de de d'acceptation par les habitants et
pour les élus parce que c'est ça souvent
qui pose aussi des difficultés de
construire des méthaniseurs pour
permettre aux agriculteurs de mettre
leurs déchets des cultures de leur
culture de mettre ce qu'on appelle
lessive de mettre les pulls de betterave
la poussière alimentaire et donc de
produire de l'énergie qui va être
injecté dans le réseau de gaz qui va
permettre de de fabriquer du digestat
pour de nouveaux être épendu sur les les
terres agricoles et donc d'avoir un
cercle plus vertueux possible donc on a
depuis 2016 un peu plus de 50
méthaniseurs installés en Île-de-France
je dirais que là on est plutôt sur voilà
je vais pas dire une pause mais on est
plus sur une croissance aussi importante
que les années précédentes on a encore
et encore des projets en magasin et puis
il y a aussi la méthanisation qui va
petit à petit se tourner vers les bi
déchets puisque au 1er janvier 2024 nous
aurons les Français auront pour
obligation de trier leurs déchets et
d'avoir une filière enfin
collecte des biodéchets et donc il va
falloir se bio d'échecs les traiter donc
une des pistes c'est effectivement la
méthanisation donc c'est des sujets sur
lesquels voilà la Région accompagne la
région a évolue la région s'adapte c'est
vraiment le choix de notre présidente de
vraiment s'adapter de d'être aussi sur
la recherche l'innovation parce qu'on
voit bien que pour aider nos
agriculteurs et donner cette envie de de
se convertir à l'agriculture ou de
reprendre une exploitation familiale il
faut aussi qu'on soit sur le volet
innovation pour rendre ces métiers moins
pénibles moins dépendants et puis on
sait que les jeunes sont très attirés
par tout ce qui est nouvelle technologie
et innovation c'est vrai que voilà c'est
une opportunité à ne pas négliger la
croûte pour finir le cinquième axe et
dernier donc du pacte régional agricole
favoriser le manger francilien les
circuits courts ont la cote 12 millions
de Franciliens donc c'est un marché non
négligeable aucune autre région ne peut
en dire autant la Région a lancé un plan
régional pour une alarme alimentation
donc locale durable et solidaire un des
objectifs atteints donc les 100% de
lycée public francilien approvisionnés
avec des produits locaux donc 50% en
produits bio d'ici à l'année prochaine
en 2024 est-ce que l'objectif sera tenu
alors c'est un objectif très ambitieux
donc c'est vrai que c'est voilà on le
souhaite même si on voit bien que le sur
le bio c'est le bio-pen un peu en ce
moment puisque le bio quand on voit la
difficulté de de nos administrer en
termes de pouvoir d'achat on sent qu'il
y a voilà une petite je dirais un léger
fléchissement du bio donc notre objectif
c'est vraiment dans glisser d'être sur
du circuit court c'est à dire du produit
local si les bio c'est encore mieux
l'objectif des 50% j'espère qu'on y
arrivera
2024-2025 mais c'est là aussi notre
objectif mais c'est surtout d'arriver à
avoir cette filière cette industrie
agroalimentaire qui permet de produire
de transformer et d'avoir assez
suffisamment de produits de quantité
pour pouvoir alimenter les lycées donc
il y a toute une chaîne
alimentaire de transformation de
production qui nécessite beaucoup de
travail et donc c'est un travail que
l'on fait depuis déjà maintenant de
plusieurs années il y a eu énormément de
progrès et donc effectivement nos lycées
nos chefs de cuisine dans les lycées
maintenant grâce à cette plateforme que
nous avons mis en place à la région
Île-de-France peuvent aller chercher sur
cette centrale d'achat des produits
locaux de plus en plus important avec un
choix de plus en plus important et puis
produit bio donc
j'espère qu'on atteindra ce pourcentage
en tout cas on en est pas loin et c'est
vraiment le souhait de l'ensemble de
l'exécutif régional et de la présidente
de pouvoir aller dans cette direction et
on le sait la souveraineté alimentaire
nous le rappelle tous les jours merci
beaucoup Valérie la croûte merci à vous
avec nous dans les deux petits je
rappelle donc que vous êtes
vice-présidente LR de la région
Île-de-France en charge de l'agriculture
et de l'alimentation nous on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro de l'hebdopolitique très bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]